[Music]
hey
everybody it's wednesday yeah i think
yeah i don't know what the hell day it
is
all right so uh the movie we're gonna be
talking about today is kind of an
interesting one i came across this one
uh when i just did a search on tubey for
2020 horror
and i was like ooh an old-fashioned
british ghost story
that's my jam so i decided uh to go
ahead and watch it last night and you
know what
it was pretty good although i noticed
that um
on imdb it has like wildly divergent
uh reviews like some people are just
like this is
you know actual trash and like talking
about how like shitty the acting was and
stuff like that yeah they're full of
[ __ ]
which i didn't really yeah it's like
okay so the thing about it
the guy i don't think they understand i
don't think they understand the genre
this is british horror he's going back
to like hammer
and the 70s you know what i mean with
like you know the the [ __ ] the legacy
and and and you know i mean it's moving
like that
yeah so i don't know what they expected
it's an updated version of that
yeah definitely that's what i'm saying
ghost watch i really i loved ghost watch
actually we should actually review that
one of these days
i don't think you've ever seen it yeah
and get back to your spiel now i don't
even know you remember where you were no
of course
you remember where you were okay because
you're always like interrupting okay
that's part of the show though if i
don't [ __ ] interrupt though i'll
never get to say anything
i don't know if that's yeah i'll never
get to say anything i don't think that's
the case
okay go ahead but apparently this movie
okay so it was written
produced and directed by this guy named
charlie steeds now i never heard of this
guy before but
apparently he's kind of well known in
the indie cheapy
like you know low budget horror scene
and normally
he makes stuff that's like real i mean
because i looked at his imdb page and
like some of the stuff
i was just kind of like oh he makes like
real cheapy [ __ ] like you know vampire
virus
cannibal farm that kind of stuff so this
would seem
a little bit of a departure for him i
guess but the thing about it is that
this movie does not seem cheap in the
slightest i mean the cinematography
the the location shots everything like
that it seemed like a really nice uh
you know little really nice production
value i thought it doesn't look all that
cheap to me i
say no i didn't you know i ain't saying
nothing
well you can say things you just you can
say things i just said you always tend
to like interrupt me like in the middle
of a sentence
that's why i think it's dumb that you
say it's like oh you'd never get to say
anything because it's like
all the time like stop so you can talk
all right the reason i get mad is
because you interrupt me in the middle
of [ __ ]
i thought the movie was good i don't
know i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about
i don't know either right it's pretty
good yeah yeah i mean for that kind of
thing
yeah so i mean basically i looked up
because apparently they shot this in
like a real uh country house in england
obviously they didn't have enough money
to like
location that's cool location yeah and i
looked on imdb and apparently somebody
said it was like some country house in
warwickshire like one of those you know
landed gentry
couples that own [ __ ] chapel it did
i just had a [ __ ] chapel on the
grounds looking into eight full-fledged
football you know you're winning when
your
house has a had your own chapel in it
like it was like full-size like yeah
full-size church
i mean it looked like it was an old
house obviously like it didn't look like
it had been updated is what i'm saying
the rooms were kind of small did you
notice that though yeah they were yeah
but it was a giant giant giant house
with a bunch of little tiny rooms in it
yeah it looked like needed some new
wallpaper say
but yeah so uh this movie in case we
didn't mention it was called an english
haunting
so i watched the trailer and i'm like
ooh that looks like some
woman in black you know 70s throwback
kind of [ __ ] it's like i'm into that
so i watched it so basically the story
is
there's this i didn't realize this when
i was watching it i guess but
i i don't know if that just means i'm
dumb or what but apparently this was
supposed to be
set in the 60s and 70s hence why nobody
had cell phones while the cars were
older
all that kind of i guess that didn't
really occur to me i was just kind of
like oh it's just like
i couldn't tell i thought it was an
homage flick because yeah i did too
they come up to the english manor you
know and they're [ __ ] driving and one
of
those
it's like a rolls that's old rules i
think it was the rose wouldn't it or is
it bad i think it or
yeah i can just it's just an old retro
british car you know how they were
[ __ ] british made cool cars they were
cool looking
you open the hood and you went like what
the [ __ ] but you know what i mean ticket
where's the engine it hasn't got one it
runs on
english magic yeah what the hell you
know what i mean
but uh they were cool looking british
and how the british knew how a car
should look
they're stylish just like man then
lucas electrics in there and [ __ ]
nothing worked now the switches work
wires and start [ __ ] crumbling but
you looked cool doing it and that's
what's really important i feel like cute
little cars made out of nothing that's
what they
brought that's what they they were yeah
they knew how a car should look yeah
you know so yeah so the story behind
this one
is that i guess it's sometime in the 60s
and 70s it doesn't really matter
um and you get like a mom named
margo and her son who's
probably in his 20s i guess he looks
like but college age
named blake and they have been summoned
to this old country house which
apparently belonged to their grandfather
whose name is aubry
they get called there by mrs clark who i
guess
or miss clark who i guess is the
housekeeper
nurse something or other and she's
basically like well your grandfather has
like gone into a comatose state it's
like he's you know he's not long for
this world and like the nurse that we
had before
um she left and uh so we need somebody
here to take care of him like until
uh you know he pops his clogs as they
say in the uk
so the funny thing about it is that
there's a very weird
so i guess there's like some family
history here which they don't
go super into but it's mostly by
implication because the mom margot
who is this hilarious like really bitter
drunk and i kind of love her um
she is basically standing in front of
her you know her dad's bed and he's
laying there with his mouth hanging open
he's got long hair looking like
mick garris by the way of christopher
lee with the [ __ ]
oxygen on and everything and she's
basically there smoking like drinking a
glass of wine being like
man can't wait till he croaks you know
what i mean just basically is what she's
saying
and uh you know her son is kind of like
why are you so mean mom goddamn
hold on the guys in there ask the
british guys are asking about the car
that car was not a citroen as far as i
could tell it looked like a
it looked like a big morgan or a big
mga you know or rolls or something it
had
yeah i thought it was a rolls but i'm
not sure swooped fenders and [ __ ]
uh had you know like uh what do you call
them
[ __ ] boards going along the side you
can stand on it it's white
yeah yeah i think it was i think it was
some kind of a rolls or some kind of a
bentley
something like that it's like a luxury
car something your driver would drive
you around with you know
which they had yeah and the driver of
the car looked eerily like ray bradbury
yeah and the church was not in the house
it was on
it was on it was on the ground it wasn't
in the actual church yeah
it was a green house and there was
something [ __ ] out in the back off to
the side was a
full-size [ __ ] church it looked like
a damn
cathedral in the inside of it thai roof
and everything yeah
look you know probably seat about
100 people maybe maybe not that many
probably more like 60.
see probably seat about 60 people had
pews and everything
yeah it was nice it wasn't it was old
though you could tell you know
well yeah it wasn't a modern structure
it was victorian probably
yeah i would think the the rooms in the
house were kind of small the ones that
they showed
yeah and like i said they looked kind of
crappy like yeah in the sense that no
one had
painted them or replaced any wallpaper
in the bedrooms and stuff
it looked like the house had kind of
been abandoned for a while yeah
so they've been on the market and they
just were able to read it and make a
movie that's kind of what i'm thinking
because
if you know i don't know a great deal
about this director but apparently he
makes like pretty
like low budget stuff so for him to have
made a movie
in this environment um probably wouldn't
have been too expensive it reminded me
of a classic
70s british horror movie that was the
tone that was the way it looked
it reminded me a lot of like the legacy
uh what else is another movie that this
that this reminded you of visually
well like i said it gave me kind of a
woman in black vibe um
thematically it reminded me of
hereditary even though it's
not it had elements of like it had
elements of that story it didn't really
like look like it it's like they were
trying it looks like the director was
trying to take that vintage
70s kind of late 60s 70s
british horror movie and tried to update
he tried to update it with some like
heredity stuff it worked
yeah it worked i thought and um if any
of you guys have seen any like uh
movies that were based on like dennis
wheatley novels they kind of gave me
that kind of vibe too
like the devil rides out that kind of
stuff there's some homages you know i
mean like
one of the women in there is kind of
reminded us of uh
carrie's mom from carrie yeah at one
stage she kind of had that
frizzy hair and she was like kind of
dressed like that
that can't have been an accident no
and uh creepy [ __ ] in there you know
what i mean like it kind of reminded me
of
certain like horror video games like a
fatal frame
where you're going along and you're
finding films and recordings and tapes
of somebody who was doing
weird [ __ ] in the past and you you've
got a lot of gruesome stuff on the tapes
you're not really sure exactly
what the context is it was kind of it
was kind of neat
you know yeah it was kind of like that
so basically like the mom
and the son um are in this house with
the grandpa
up in the attic who is ostensibly dying
and also there's like some creepy [ __ ]
happening too
which seems like some ghost action like
you know little toy trains like doors
opening
uh blake's having like really creepy
nightmares
um seeing somebody with like a face that
looks kind of like
um the doctor from house by the cemetery
like some other [ __ ] like that going on
and as he
continues the investigation they kind of
figure out like what the secret of the
house is
and like what the grandpa was up to and
you know what so
and like i said it's not really a
spoiler alert but it does
it is like sort of a hereditary type of
direction that it goes in but yeah it's
like it's really weird because
i actually had a great time with this
movie because like i said haunted house
movies like old english ghost stories so
if i love
that kind of [ __ ] so you know i i give
movies like that and stories like that a
lot of leeway
because i really like that genre that
sub genre
um so i think it's really strange how
there were some people on imdb that were
just like giving it one star
half a star to being like talking about
how awful it was
and i'm like i don't know like i
i can see how like the acting was a
little bit it wasn't bad but it was like
just shaded on the side of campy a
little bit like a little over
ripe but that kind of suited the tone
of it though so i didn't really mind it
all that much
um it was just kind of like all of a
piece of those kind of like throwback
type of movies
from that time period so it didn't
really bother me it wasn't really
i don't know it wasn't distracting or
anything like that they're asking about
the car again yeah the car had running
boards
car had run had big swoopy front fetters
and running boards you could stand on it
you know as it was a winner
or at least you know they made it look
like you could i think it was some kind
of jack
some kind of a rolls royce yeah they
didn't really show the
the hood ornament or any of the tags
yeah it was just kind of like pulling up
in front of that big old gravel
it might have been a driveway this might
have been a replica for all i know i
don't know
i wonder how much it cost to rent those
nowadays like for a movie probably not
much i heard
i heard that a lot of those real old
luxury cars aren't really worth much
nobody rich people don't want them too
old because
well they're too old and maybe too
ostentatious they don't want people
nowhere
have you ever seen inside one of those
cars though you can go on youtube
and you know guys buy them yeah and you
look inside and it's just kind of like
stale interiors
and you're like oh man because you you
don't realize how much [ __ ] has changed
over the years
yeah yeah i mean they're just kind of
crappy well i mean if you have
a [ __ ] ton of money you know it
it seems like you would be it would
behoove you to like buy something has
all the like bells and whistles
on it yeah but the bells and whistles
are maybe like a cigarette lighter
that's what i mean
and you know which i mean by which i
mean something new
yeah exactly if you have money you're
going to get the brand new rolls you
know
[ __ ] you know they have half a
million dollar car yeah you would think
i mean unless you just like collect them
and like to look at it yeah and
evidently there's not a big market for
the old ones
like you know guys have collections of
them they just sit there they have a
hard time moving them in this country
yeah i can see that and they don't
really have any like powered
features like no powered windows and the
air can the ac isn't that good
i remember back in the old days yeah
hold on a second
and then like uh some one guy was
driving one round he's like this thing
feels like [ __ ]
yeah well i mean have power steering or
anything did they i don't think so
and so yeah and the brakes weren't very
good
and you couldn't really go fast on the
thing and it [ __ ] you know what i
mean it
just the ride was terrible by today's
standards you know the ford taurus would
ride a lot better
yeah which is really funny to think
about to think about it but yeah a
little ford focus like
yeah now like even shitty little cars
that aren't even that expensive
she had this this [ __ ] what was that
thing it was a honda fit
how to fit it was a 2013 yeah
i couldn't believe it man i was coming
out of my mustang
i had to [ __ ] divorce duels and [ __ ]
that thing was like driving a [ __ ]
bomber
it was it felt like it was real low to
the ground i get in her car and i was
like laughing i was scoffing at that
thing
took it out on the freeway wasn't
watching the [ __ ] speedo i was going
120 miles an hour that thing didn't even
yeah i used to do that
but this thing's flying because it
doesn't weigh anything doesn't weigh
anything it's like so
and you're just i've done that many many
years and like i said you don't feel
anything you feel like you're going slow
i tried to keep up with you one time you
were outrunning me
and i wasn't even paying attention and i
was like going like i
yeah i sold the mustang i sold the
mustang i realized
i sold my fit too mustang was just uh
made you feel like you're going fast but
comparison to modern car was like
driving a truck
yeah yeah worse i mean i liked that
little fit but
you know it was it was a nice little car
but yeah that's
the thing that bothered me about it like
i said it was it's very light
so not only could you go super fast
without realizing it if you weren't
looking at your
uh speedometer but also when you went
over an overpass and it was
on a windy day it felt like it was going
to blow off the side of the overpass it
would be like whoa
it didn't weigh anything it was big on
the inside it's like a big hollow box
yeah a big holocaust it looked really
small like from the outside because even
when i went to the lot like to buy it
you know we were like wow that's kind of
dinky but then like when i got in there
i was like whoo
look at all those like bigger on it was
like a tardis it's like
on the inside than the tardis doctor who
showed the doctor
tom baker riding with you with his scarf
flying yeah you want a jelly baby
no you can have that i don't know what
they taste like unless it's well it's
like a jelly bean that's jelly
they're jelly beans that's just what
they call them unless it's the popcorn
flavor one i know a lot of people don't
like the popcorn flavor ones
you know but those i like those
but yeah so the [ __ ] gap
[ __ ] got some dead air there yeah so
anyway like like i said if you like old
school
english horror movies like ghost stories
haunted houses like old creepy mansions
old creepy dudes you know family
secrets all kind of [ __ ] going to like
creepy wine cellars all that kind of
crap
um i feel like you would probably dig
this i had a good time with it like i
said it's not the best movie ever it's
not
you know it wasn't as good as like you
know the woman in black or something
like that
or some of the ones from the 70s but it
was a perfectly entertaining
uh entry into that genre and uh you know
kind of a throwback to the 70s it was
kind of cool in some weird way i might
put it up there with
kind of like layer of the white worm
maybe it was a lot less weird than lara
the white worm
i had forgotten because we reviewed that
a couple months ago i had forgotten how
weird that
movie was well when it was ken russell
when he was showing you know
what they were doing on the old [ __ ]
film it kind of was
it was kind of eerie i thought it was
kind of eerie yeah
yeah it wasn't as good as the white worm
i guess guess the white worm [ __ ] you
know what i mean
it was it was a little more bizarre yeah
and that's not even ken russell's
weirdest movie like by a long style but
it was good you know it's just
i'd probably put it up there with like
the legacy
yeah it reminded me of that kind of
thing where there was like a lot of
you know creeping around in this house
and they're like investigating
like you know secret rooms and all that
kind of [ __ ] and like you know the
the old tape and like with the creepy
voice on it and
yeah seeing stuff out in the [ __ ]
yard and [ __ ] like that changeling maybe
kind of like to change things yeah
george c scott which we also reviewed
yeah which you know so this wasn't as
good as that but yeah
changing is kind of a masterpiece in a
certain way uh it is yeah definitely
it kind of reminded me tonally of that
and it's kind of like
i don't know i'm going to go back to the
legacy or maybe like the evil
yeah like that um with some updated
stuff from like heredity in it
yeah like a black man like a like a
[ __ ] satanic [ __ ]
ritual magic you know and witches and
[ __ ] that kind of
that kind of spin on it and and a little
bit like a mystery and a ghost story all
well it's you know it's definitely
british
it is very impressive it had that
british [ __ ] style to it so
i think it i don't give a [ __ ] they they
said they didn't like it and that the
movie was char
was trash and everything no it's not
trash no i've seen it
i think it's pretty good i thought it
was pretty good too like i said and i
like that genre i know i'm kind of
forgiving
i think some people said it's like oh
the characters weren't that likable like
particularly the mom are you i was like
are you crazy i loved the mom she was
[ __ ] awesome
because she was just like she was just a
bitter horrible old
bat that drank all the time and she was
just like always talking about how much
everything sucked
she was awesome could be that they were
kind of wanting
more of american tone where it's like
comedy horror you know like i like that
too
yeah and if you were looking if you were
expecting that then no
this is more like long lines of like
heredity and
[ __ ] mid-summer maybe and mixed with
the [ __ ] ghost
british ghost story like something about
a hammer you know or 70s ghost
story you know that's but i thought it
was
i thought i thought it was effective i
think he i think he captured the genre
and like i said i and the cinematography
was very nice too i thought like
especially like the opening shots oh the
score was also really good
yeah like it had a very um what is the
word i'm looking for like the
the score sounded like a very it sounds
weird to say like a professional score
but you know you see some of these like
really cheapy indie movies that don't
even have a score or they're just kind
of like half-assed or something but this
one was like really
this was like some harry potter [ __ ] or
something like that it had like a really
nice like hollywood style score you know
what i mean
it's a flick it's a flick i don't know i
might even i might even like bump this
up to movie
i don't even think this was a flick okay
well
flick kind of implies like a garbage
movie but in a good way yeah you know
what i mean
well see the thing is is like a lot of
those 70s british
movies like we're talking about i kind
of consider them to be flicks though in
a way
yeah i guess you could make that
argument they were low budget you know
what i mean but yeah they were effective
though they did what they're supposed to
do
i mean i mean what i'm thinking about
flick i'm thinking about something like
blood feast yeah that's a flick you know
what i mean well that's def that's
unapologetically a flick i feel like
even if something costs the same to make
as
blood feast but was trying to be like
classy as [ __ ]
like look at what roger corman did with
the edgar allen poe adaptations
i would not call those flicks it's
spiritual you know what i mean it's a
spirit it's a spiritual thing
because because escape from new york's a
flick but that's one of my favorite
movies
one of my most favorite flicks i guess
it's a good one
but you know you you can tell it has an
underground feel to it and it was
it was trying to be like a movie of its
time like you know like a warriors or
something you know
yeah like that that's true they were
into gang movies that was starting to
come
come about you know yeah my favorite
thing was all the gangs that were like
you know
movies well they they all had like they
were all clothing coordinated i thought
that was really nice
yeah how everybody had meetings they had
a weekly gang meeting so they could
decide like what the theme of their
outfits was going to be that week
in between all the drug dealing and rape
and murder certain elements of escape
from new york i think kind of came from
like death wish three though too
yeah i don't know my death wish three
might might have been after
after before i'm not sure but it didn't
really matter
about 2000 maniacs i love 2000 matings
but you know what the hd
herschel gordon lewis the movie that of
his that a lot of people don't talk
about that i like was color me blood red
i don't know why i just always have kind
of a soft spot for calling me blood red
i mean i like two thousand maniacs too
didn't they make a i think they made a
sequel event that i'm pretty sure i saw
but i can't remember i don't know what
happened you'd probably like those those
are definitely flicks
super super cheap i lost my little feed
here oh no
yeah all right well we've talked
probably about half an hour for this so
okay you know what i mean all right so
uh this is our last live stream
of the week we'll be doing another one
on saturday night for our regular
episode
yeah i think sophie's gonna be and
sophie will be here she'll be here on
the next two probably and she'll
probably be on some [ __ ] that we record
too right
not the movie will be this week but
probably the one next weekend yeah we'll
put her to work
make her do some stuff
well yeah because otherwise she's just
going to be sitting back there i'm going
to make her do my
make her feel in for me you don't even
want to be on this
i'm going to be here you're going to
take a vacation i'll take a vacation
she's going to use her as my stand here
no i could i wouldn't do that we'll make
her do the show by herself
mcdonald's you can't get a pizza he's
take care of this she's vegan on your
feet right
you stay here we're gonna get something
going with chinese
i don't think there's anything vegan in
china [ __ ] koi wan
china buffet oh there's there is there's
like there's all kind of salad stuff and
some kind of like well yeah that's the
thing well that's the thing with buffets
it's like you don't know
even if it's you know vegan in the thing
you don't know if it's touched
yeah i've been over there with those
yeah cutting it on the same cutting on
the cutting board is the meat or like
cooking it on the same thing is that you
know they're doing that
yeah i'm sure they probably are they
they say they're not but they're just
like yeah we're not doing it guys are
working fast man they don't care
don't worry about the white people
they're like whatever i'm gonna just
wait
i'm not gonna eat it so it's like i'm
not worried about it yeah
what's funny to go to chinese buffet now
they don't have chinese people working
in there they're just they're running it
but it's uh everybody everybody in the
kitchen is from mexico and honduras and
nicaragua
who needed jobs at the time yeah are you
guys hurricane and flooding safe
um so far
[Laughter]
we'll see we've been through a couple of
hurricanes at this house i guess
well i think houses in this uh part of
the
country in florida you have to have uh
it has to be hurricane safe up to it
although i think if it's older than
a certain time and it's grandfathered in
and then you're on your own
but then but the newer stuff they have
to have all the hurricane safety
measures
yeah and you know we have generators and
everything so if we lose power i just
pump power back into the house
we still and we still have gasoline for
that don't we because yeah i got
gasoline yeah because we were
afraid that one was going to hit before
and so we bought gas but it never hit
so yeah we have generators we have all
kind of [ __ ] we'll be all right
and i don't think um it would have to be
the flooding would have to be pretty
high
like to mess up our house we're not near
the ocean
well now nope nope yeah so we should be
all right all right so uh that'll do it
for
our review of an english haunting and
all of the other
tendrils that we went off on like we
always do so uh
we will see you guys again live on
saturday sophie will be here
and it'll all be a fun time we'll all
drink we'll talk about some fun [ __ ]
well
it's probably not fun should i have to
figure out the damn camera angles
yeah we're going to like put her in the
middle yeah
we'll figure something we'll have to
move way back here
have to put we'll have to get that
[ __ ] laptop over here on the table
yeah so we can back up to get all three
of us in camera
yeah like i said we'll figure it out we
got time
all right so uh thanks you guys for
dropping by and we will uh
see you in a couple of days bye